on comprends moi l'âge que j'ai bon
c'est vrai que on peut rester en couple
au en petit comité
20h20 va se retrouver une raquette comme
des gens de 55 ans donc un pour des gens
qui ont entre 21 ou 28 vraiment pas le
nouvel an dont on aurait rêvé pour moi
c'est pas normal à 20 heures parce que
les gens ils vont aller visiter les
premiers pc
il faut au moins à l'essai jusqu'à des
notes pour la sécurité tout le monde je
trouve ça très bien que les gens se
protègent et qui respecte les autres les
horaires on espère qu'on va quand même
le faire même si c'est pas trop légale
en vrai c'est pas top mais c'est pour
notre moral aussi parce que en plus on
travaille on en est on est jeune on nous
dise tous 20 ans c'est trop cool c'est
l'année pour profiter on est jeune on
est beau on s'aime et on peut même pas
profiter ensemble et je trouve ça hyper
triste